[Musique]
vous qui êtes avec nous ou qui nous
balance tout ce qui se passe dans
l'émission elle voit tout et je peux
vous dire qu'il ya de la grosse balle en
solo oui il ya du gros gros gros
dossiers dans un instant bien sûr draw
et demi qu'on a dit on fera quand même
un petit tour du paf on à du très lourd
comment elle va ma poupée moi je vais
très bien je suis tout excité soir
pourquoi aussi j'ai trop de choses à
vous montrer l'un ouais c'est vrai oui
oui j'ai fondé ma en direct alors oui
carrément
et j'ai envie de remettre des poux qui
dort ce soir à j'adore c'est quoi alors
mais quand on arrive à concentrer autant
de talents autour d'une seule et même
table basse a produit quelque ou
vraiment merci
alors comment c'est que le bouquet de la
langue de vipère 1
abbas et de leurs vols à bas coût ont
selon m non la langue mais non mais
c'est de lanvaux non non bien sûr que
oui c'est
[Musique]
les images on a des images bouquet
démontage
[Musique]
c'est l'e3 caudecostois été tellement
plus fort ses talons talons
bull
et jean tailleur
les trois plus gros salaires moi ça
c'est grave
d'ailleurs il pas y revenir c'est
vraiment bon
ça nous a fait nos jean-michel et
castaldi
c'est l'animé score est très décevant
lui
le petit
je ne sais pas ce que tu entends ça me
permet de dire qu'elle fait une mauvaise
émission paul dhaeyer belle ma démission
est une très mauvaise ça dépend des gens
a fait neuf fois sur dix est très bonne
et oui mais en tant que co animateur je
me dois aussi de juger les oreilles des
bons et des mauvais points aux
animateurs savants plissés ensemble les
gens de savon préparant réunion qui sera
là qui sera pas là et on peut sortir des
coulisses avec 1
ça c'est un tout petit pas ce que je
vais prendre la défense de castaldi à la
pub sinon on a bien sûr beaucoup de
téléspectateurs nous ont demandés s'il y
avait une suite aux aventures
trépidantes de baba et cast ap
oui bah oui quand même alors moi comme
un petit bon soldat j'ai regardé les
images et je suis tombé sur une
déclaration d'amour une déclaration
d'amour plutôt louche entre cyril et
benjamin d'en garder un architecte ados
[Musique]
quelque chose je vais faire une
déclaration d'amour à vendre 42 gossips
à jour et faire une déclaration d'amour
que j'aime énormément et parfois il peux
m'énerver x parce que c'est comme on se
chamaille vernon c'est un mec que j'aime
énormément et il sait que je ne
laisserai jamais c'est vrai c'est vrai
oui vous aussi vous vous dites que c'est
louche c'est éclairé six mois tesla vous
que vous vous dites sûrement que c'est
louche ses déclarations donc oui donc
j'ai freiné un petit peu plus et j'ai
trouvé les images qui explique cette
déclaration ci et là on comprend mieux
on comprend beaucoup mieux la raison
fait
[Applaudissements]
t'es mignon c'était mignon c'est mignon
le premier oui quoi là-bas il a caché si
questa il s'en veut beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup que la grande gueule mail
d'étals comme un lapin quand vous
approchez de l'iniquité petite équipe à
la normale à ma tête et qu'elle allait
faire bouger les doigts car à la base
j'ai tellement l'habitude je n'arrivais
plus à bouger les doigts tellement que
tu es ça va mais c'est pas le malin toi
qui fais attention à toi pour une paire
menaces et toi tu menaces personne mais
personne pour ça d'accord benjamin calme
toi tu sais qu'il pense parce que tu es
ça sert à rien de fermer les yeux tu les
as dit alors tendez mathieu arrêter de
jouer le malin parce que hein je vous
rassure vous n'êtes pas les seuls
membres de l'équipe à vous embrouiller
tout le temps est aussi un petit duo qui
à deux doigts vous piquer la vedette est
passé mathieu izard qui sont vraiment
c'est bien oui comme chiens et chats
quoi sert il a adoré tcc tarik
benhabilès et nadal
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'inconnu
regardez une carte end il a fait un
mauvais score et reste dans ta chambre
envers le thème dans tout
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout était parfait
bien qu il a quittée pas beaucoup mais
je m'attache bouvier comme ça près vous
êtes à côté elle poche mais c'est vrai
on s'attache aux gens que vous avez vous
c'était moins pire que ce que je pensais
vraiment attendu moi parce que c'est
mieux avec alain à la bugatti à elle
change de préférer les manches ça vous
laisse une panne est gigantesque
vous vous dites la belle chanteuse
préférée des moches ça me dit ça mais
pas elle a préféré quelqu'un là il est
magnifique très beau bien sûr de loin il
était en plus jeunes en ce moment je
tenais à vous le dire vous êtes
dégueulasse
ça fait mal vous là elle a pris sur
scène la famille ma carrière mon intérêt
c'est le plus beau de la rangée merci
[Rires]
maman l'a rangé la semaine dernière dans
notre épisode d'un confesseur secrète
vous en souvenez confession secrète
oui bien sûr voilà on vous avez vu avec
votre petite maladie votre petit ogre
oui j'en être toutes les affaires de
benjamin dans votre salon je tiens à
dire où c'est vraiment je suis juste cc
c'est plus fort que moi c'est plus fort
que moi c'est ça à ces attaques
d'ailleurs on va découvrir le deuxième
épisode je les lis pas sûr parce que
dans si la personne concernée nous
regarde juste
je voudrais dire c'est vraiment c'est
parce que je ne peux pas m'en empêcher
ouais je vous dis on n'allait vraiment
pas essayer de vous soigner mais en tout
cas oui j'ai les images vous avez une
petite facette de votre personnalité qui
décidément m'épate
de plus en plus et chaque jour je
regardais l'a fait
[Musique]
on
la pression est la même au téléphone
dans son usine
[Musique]
c'est pas ça que je pensais en être un
choix très vaste et rien n'a pas l'air
comme ça mais il est propre support face
à lui des profs des cas 4 sa bonne
séquence est toujours chic c'est
vraiment un virus et odeurs qui n'ont
pas de qui et odeurs qui n'ont pas
d'odeur et les odeurs fortes odeurs mais
bien sûr et bien sûr à la raison dire
qu'il permet des choses qui seraient
néfastes sur son portable que vous avez
mois alors moi je vous dis aux syriens
de défense n est ce pas pour qui oui
bien sûr et kelly c'est bien retenez
bien ce que vous venez de dire parce
qu'en fait j'ai petit exclu pour vous
oui vous voulez voir un petit état perçu
de confession secrète de la semaine
prochain la caisse qu'il a fallu rouler
smara ballet d'accord elle il va suivait
attentivement ces images mais je ne vous
êtes pas les bruits du kif visionnage
kelly mais c'est pas moi
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en échange
ce qui m'a plu et j'ai vraiment pas les
mines je sais pas de bouton de fièvre à
l'âge les enquêteurs vous appris non
mais mais j'ai vu quelque chose très des
voix là et j'ai craqué j'ai craqué car
open j'ai craqué nerveusement week a dit
oui il faut faire soigner ouais mais là
vraiment c'est important facteur dans
les restos ont fait ça chez vous hubert
bajramaj ans j'adore cette idée
will et qui vivent dans l'histoire c'est
vous vous laissez traîner vos affaires
aussi dans bsf à les ranger ses affaires
vous savez que ya des gens qui sont
bizarre ici on va se méfier maintenant
regarde j'ai fait la même chose et que
votre sandwich je ne touche pas la
nourriture qu'il y aura deux choses dit
bien sûr
alors cette saison nous avons la chance
d'avoir dans l'équipe eric naulleau un
intellectuel amoureux d'art et de
lettres et lui aussi il a de la chance
parce qu'il est lui aussi vraiment bien
tomber en arrivant sur tes pmp c'est un
véritable bouillon de culture pour lui
chaque soir
la preuve en images parce que faire
attention
là elle te dis qu'elle pense comme toi
et qu'elle veut te retrouver mais elle
est à distance c'est facile de le dire
mais fais attention à ce qu'elles le
pensent vraiment ce qu'elle te dit et
fais surtout attention c'est qu'à un
moment donné quand vous allez vous
retrouver ça va chambrer le cantique le
quotidien et c'est comme ça que vous
vous plaisez deuxièmement deuxièmement
il va falloir
à un moment donné
[Musique]
je suis qu'un faux pour enfin me suis
tombé
je suis tombé m pokora jacky ça je peux
pleurer quand tu m'appelles
[Musique]
mais non c'est énorme ça ça c'est vous
et vous dire ça ça met une séquence
récurrentes
eric naulleau oui mais qui s'intègrent
bien comment s'intègrent bien il arriva
voilà c'est vrai qu'on sur la côte et le
mouchoir occupé en est on est à auxerre
mais votre tabouret plus bas que les
autres
sa carrière aller d'autres choses
bouclées
bien sûr cyril plus je scrute des images
de vous et plus finalement je découvre
un homme un homme nouveau ou un coût
plus calme ces volumes échangés
tranquille plus apaisé reste que normal
oui ça non je déconne évidemment
absolument beau on regarde les i
mettez-vous droit soyez fiers d'être
dans l'émission soyez fiers d'être
larmes
[Musique]
le mmo cusa la bataille continue
j'ai vu ta culotte j'ai vu ta culotte de
l'écarter de santé le vigan route a été
difficile
motivés pour motiver ces années là sur
quoi est ce que vous faites au times je
suis sympa j'ai su attaquer personne
d'abord on soit la date de demande si ça
va mon chéri moi j'aime beaucoup moins
merci pour les retrouvera remettre un
jour je vous arrive de vous poser des
questions existentielles un petit peu
sur votre vie ce qui se passe dans votre
tête dans votre corps le soir
ouais une remise en question web
streamiz en question non des états d'âme
du comment il est vivant une vie saine
et chez syrie et tout le monde le sait
aussi j'insiste là dessus chaque semaine
des pmp site une grande et belle famille
avec des vraies valeurs de l'amour de
l'amitié et surtout de la sincérité bas
beaucoup beaucoup de sincérité et c'est
ça la tp family c'est ça qu'on aime
exactement
[Musique]
à munich
m
[Musique]
je les remets ça
j'ai passé le vote au moins 30 minutes
j'ai moi-même et n'étudie le travail le
travail me gêne vous aimez sûr jamais
je vais pas vous qu'un jeune ait pas les
sujets mais des civils
[Musique]
je la trouve mignonne comme tout
pourquoi les mains pourquoi tu n'es tu
vas t'on pas vignes l'aluminium comme
c'est pas mon délire elle est
dégueulasse
[Musique]
je suis malade
[Applaudissements]
on sait pas ce que je disais merci vers
l'aval cristina cordula hexagram voilà
quoi mais parce que vous pensez quoi du
refoud alors jolie du monde le sait il
aurait pas dit je leur ai pas dit et
voilà allez-y non mais vous vous êtes
magnifique arrêté je vous le dis tout le
temps en coûtera que j'ai encore une
photo d'elle une photo d'elle il reçoit
encore vous êtes mais vous êtes
franchement la plus belle femme autour
de la table j'ai pas peur de le dire
là ce qui me redonne une tonne osmani
chaude on la voyait pas son avantage
mais elle est magnifique il s'agit d'un
labrador pour série ne serait pas
question si on peut apporter un labrador
chien chez bull chalon alors oui c'est
le choc
si je je je ne serai présente et encore
une personne autour de la table
bonsoir bernard la voiture qui va
tourner directement de walker texas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aie aie
c
alors j'ai calculé c'est la série où il
y avait le plus de bagarres ah ouais
ouais moi j'avais aimé y avait au moins
quinze membres bagarre par par épisode
mais en fait débat il parlait même pas
les mecs ils se battaient pour un oui
pour un non la preuve on à bercy on le
connaît on le connaît alors chanté
bernard 1 eh bien figurez vous que votre
pari de la limite haute et leurs minis
top de la semaine elle vous est dédié je
suis pas ok enfin plutôt à votre
anatomie
oui parce qu'il ya certains tours de son
bateau qui guérirait beaucoup la
découvrir ah je vous laisse découvrir ce
à dire ou à douzy oula oula
non mais là il est bon tiers auxquels il
doit avoir à saisir vraiment sans aucun
problème non monsieur ya pas de souci
dans son désir son inis un grand frère
ce lointain tweaks tu vois c'est à on
n'est pas loin on n'est pas l'antenne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci valérie merci et moi tu remercies
pas qu'on attend c'est quoi un tweaks
chocolatées la règle est la vraie
question est ce que tu fais un hub et tu
te fais totalement nue du coup ton sex
bomb aussi ou pas du tout non non je ne
fais jamais du v c'est vrai il va
accueillir alors tu mets alors tu m'as
un truc sur la tête et j'étais là
j'étais par exemple au concert pour la
tolérance ce week-end à agadir oui donc
non non j'ai pas besoin de faire du vélo
contre lequel fils de casimir non parce
que lui il est orange gp n'a rien à voir
les pauvres ont dû arrêter
non mais tu classait les origines de ces
maisons terracotta terre battue ça c'est
beaucoup plus chic
oui vous inquiétez pas bernard je vais
manger allez c'est l'heure de parler des
gros looser de l'émission galère oui on
va parler de ceux qui galèrent à prendre
la parole
j'adore que personne ne quelques jamais
voici donc le top 3 le top-3 pardon ou
des plus grands moments de solitude de
la semaine
je suis tous âges qui touche à la vie
des verrines nivôse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g milan question il faut que tu le
fasses
je sors j'ai
c'est par un très bon mondial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non plus
ce délai sera bien fait ma chérie bravo
bravo manif est alors on a on a d'autres
choses bien sûr que dans d'autres choses
dans la tpp familier je demande est bien
la plus expérimentée alors c'est qui
votre vie c'est bizarre il a bien sûr
que c'est six à sept heures d'émission à
l'heure où toutes les tables on sait un
vous m
mais savez vous comment vos collègues
surnomment usa quand vous avez le dos
tourné
la vieille un nom sur et vous cette
chose que de la bienveillance jours
allez on découvre tout ça sur qui sont
cools
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais j'ai bien envie de prendre ma
mamie élèves le clac eu 32 dents
retenez-vous ma mire retournez vous et
vous ne faites remarquer que vous nous
faites mardi
[Musique]
sa stature entièrement sa mort 2 en deux
heures avec et péter jeu du regard les
vieux jeux
nourrir le gagner
[Musique]
j'appelle pendant les vacances et leur
talent comme profession dans ses
entraînements
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime chez les jeunes et il a tu
sais qu on part ensemble là avant fin
novembre on part ensemble à marrakech
toujours ça de moi j'étais ton voyage ne
sont pas à marrakech avec jamie et is a
way s'occupe des objets la wii non
monsieur on part ensemble et j'ai envie
de choisir quelqu'un peut-être à venir
bah il choisira choisir il choisira
quelqu'un je pense qu'il va choisir
mathieu mais bien évidemment ça
m'arrange pas ce n'est que si ça se
négocie à d'accord bien bas vous verrez
en tout cas merci cirque ou pas on
partira je crois troisième semaine de
novembre machines des comptes calme tu
peux faire du sexe à l'amitié qui n'est
pas du sexe et aux fourneaux et les plus
tard qu'un tel autre chose et oui
heureusement et en n y en a un qui vous
aime vous avez d'ailleurs trouvé du
réconfort avec lui et même de l'amour
et bizarrement c'est pas à celui auquel
on pensait on se regarde ça mais c'est
qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon opinion les gars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
achat
[Musique]
c'est fait
du pays
mais tout va mais frère tu frottes la
boudeuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je tiens à le dire il ya une
amitié naissante entre vous deux vous
appelle ça des métiers toi tu as un
avoir ils s'adorent ils sont tous les
deux en main mais il aime bien ce qui
fait un peu c'est la compresse
l'attendrait j'avais franchement tu
l'avenir de l'équipe et en plus je
m'entends très bien avec alain wahba web
en france à val des gardes et non mais
vous vous auriez péter christophe oh
vous savez quoi
j'ai tellement je sais pas mais on peut
y aller lentement j'adore à l'événement
vous l'adorez way série qui mettrait
aussi comme ça fait certainement c'est
ça quand on demande à ces messages et
après c'était une attirance ou parano
vision bien à part que tant qu'on n'a
pas visité on sait pas si on va
l'acheter beaucoup plus en temps réel se
souvient de rien
[Applaudissements]
bravo par des arrivages et embêter une
petite médaille
oui celle de la façon de la radinerie
olala me dit d'où vous me devancer
toujours l'arrêt de leur vol sept aps le
radar de france mais c'est plus rare en
france et à tous les prix or ce fou et
oui le pouls qui dort de plus gros
gratteurs de l'équipe est décerné à mme
mathieu de l'amo
[Musique]
c'est quatre ans de crise 50 ans
dynaudio les rentes a pas de montant
[Musique]
les grognards quelqu'un 50 ans il moins
capés
[Musique]
[ __ ] il avait un rôle dans l'émission
j'imitais par 50 centimes merci
[Applaudissements]
dieu
voilà